that's why I was thinking we caught some
people that from my high school that
screwed me over when I was a kid
them yes I agree call them what's going
on guys Hercules is hitting theaters and
it's stars action superstar Dwayne the
rock Johnson we have a rock mega fan in
our family
Nick Mundy last year we sent Nick to
Miami to interview the rock for the pain
& gain junket I saw I've gotta talk
about painting
oh no no LOC which the head of paramount
marketing called the worst interview of
all time
we asked Paramount if we could send Nick
to interview the rock for Hercules
shockingly they said yes and to his
credit Nick Mundy took the opportunity
to do something very special thank you
for having me again man's good genius
dude it's good to see you too man I'm
glad we did this
I'm glad we're friends we're best
friends okay okay you're great Hercules
it was awesome and I just have to say
like you're not just like the greatest
action star of this generation but like
ever of all time yes and then one of my
favorite parts about the movie was you
know Hercules had a lot of bad stuff in
his past happened to him and he had
overcome it and I was thinking since
like we've become really best friends
since you just said like that if you
would help me maybe overcome some stuff
that happened to me in my past I'm here
I got her back okay great that's what I
was thinking
we caught some people that from my high
school that screwed me over when I was a
kid [ __ ] them yes I agree call them the
first guys Steven what do you do he
picked on me on high school and junior
high the worst thing was he punched me
in the balls in eighth grade at misty
maegor's birthday party in front of
everyone embarrassed me so I feel like
let's get him back to the back and like
shove in his face that we're best
friends I'm getting worked up right now
no no yeah I don't anymore and also
since you're so great at talking if you
want to just start talking and then yeah
I know how this works okay other than I
use this hey Steven it's Nick hey I'm
just hanging out with my best friend
this is Steven hey yeah Steven this is
Nick's best friend it's the rock Steven
wipe that smile off your face right now
buddy exactly in eighth grade at Misty's
party you punch Nick in the balls his
balls weren't even adult balls they were
eighth grade balls today
he's a slayer so even though you hit him
in the balls it doesn't matter he
he is slaying everywhere his nickname is
tripod it's Nick the blessing Halloween
so this is how you you bullied him you
didn't tell me that you didn't tell me
that part I forgot I'm sorry all right
hey Steven I apologize he didn't tell me
the whole [ __ ] story and I'm sorry
you got body slammed and he was dressed
like Ric Flair talk to you later
I'll call you collect I'm I'm bad dude
all right the neurosurgeon is this girl
Chavis we went to prom together and I
want to be more than friends with her
and then she don't want to be more than
friends with me oh you know what I
wanted to progress the relationship and
that night like give time I had a real
big crush on her
hey Chavis hey it's Nick Mundy hey this
is my friend Dwayne Johnson can you see
okay it's my great white John say that
smile oh it's an appropriate I can
juggler yeah that's my night you know
what's her Chavis remember when she
wouldn't be more than friends with Davis
are you doing
she's smiling did she like that's all
right I'm good I'm good don't tell me
how to write this no I know what I'm
doing
listen so you guys went to the prom Nick
wanted to be a little bit more than
friends he wanted to progress the
relationship I just want to know what
happened I was a gentleman at problem
right I mean I still love you I know by
no kid you picked on our bottom kid your
Chavis here now is there any chance
whatsoever that there's there's a a
hookup he is my best friend we are best
friend we are like twins and I just want
to know is there any chance whatsoever
under God's hot Sun that you guys are
hooking up one more time
I forgot about that forget about that I
forgot that all right you're not I'm
just let's just uh IIIi did try thank ya
I'm not good I'm not that's all right
son that's all right thank you
where we going I I got the dis move
what's the name of the movie Turkey we
shut the phone babe yeah yeah she's
still on there yeah yeah
Hercules exactly who's Hercules you are
exactly so who runs off this whole ship
you do I say that for a long time
exactly now let's do the wrap of right
all right sorry thank you man you're
just like nothing you can't do with
excitement okay thank you so much I'm
sorry uh
I was embarrassed myself again on these
things I think that next time
well next time you got to tell me you're
gonna get me to talk to your girl from
prom that you didn't pass out before the
Sun went down you know it's weird she
just sent me a picture of me passed out
that night no wow
puberty happened probably later puberty
happened never by the way yeah why are
your pants down I'm I lost my virginity
and I did not uh uh thank you so much
wow that was really impressive Nick did
you have fun oh yeah
yeah it was awesome yeah it's pretty
cool that through this show you've
gotten to become friends with the rock
and I've gotten to become friends with
Hollywood Boulevard Superman thank you
screen jockeys rule on dreams got you
again look at this face his dreams did
come true twice so if you had the chance
to have to rock tell off somebody in
your life who would it be
let us know in the comment section below
best answer well we're gonna send you a
screen junkies t-shirt I want to thank
Nick Mundy
I want to thank paramount The Rock I
want to thank Hercules himself and I
want to thank you for watching screen
junkies I'm Hal run Nikki's Nick Mundy
hit us up on Twitter bye-bye don't go on
Twitter man like I know you're gonna
watch Game of Thrones in three hours
because you're on the west coast just
don't go on Twitter for three hours but
Chiva no but that your choice that you
made the decision so